When you’re planning your data project,
try to construct questions that will allow
you to leverage the data you currently have.
It would be optimal to solve the biggest problem
your firm faces, and that should be the initial
goal.
But if you don’t have the data to answer
that question, you’ll have difficulty trying
to do so.
Consider other factors that could make your
question unsolvable.
The source of the data, or the capability
of your team.
Once you’ve determined what data is at your
disposal, ask actionable and detailed questions.
They must be detailed in order to provide
you and your data team a narrowed scope of
focus, and actionable so you can accomplish
specific results after running the analyses.
It’s helpful when your questions relate
to data that your business uses.
Your questions must be aligned with strategic
goals, which vary depending on your target
audience.
Is this analysis for internal use, a C-Suite
meeting, a client?
Figure out your audience, and adjust your
question accordingly.
Let’s imagine a scenario between two managers,
one who asks vague questions which will be
difficult to answer and one who asks direct
and actionable questions.
Andreas: How can we cut costs across the retail
company?
Katie: Can we reduce cotton materials cost
by 20% and linen materials costs by 10% from
Supplier A?
Andreas’ question is too broad to design
a study.
On the other hand, Katie’s question is detailed
and specific.
To answer her question, we’ll need cost
data for supply chain and suppliers, and our
historical relationship with suppliers.
Let’s take a look at the next set of questions.
Andreas: How can we increase our market share
in the US?
Katie: Which geographic market that we operate
in has the most potential for us to increase
our market share?
Although both Andreas and Katie are focused
on market share, Katie’s question is framed
more specifically so we can identify the data
needed.
For example, we’ll need both competitor
market shares and our market share for every
location where we have a store.
Let’s look at another example.
Andreas: Should we expand internationally?
Katie: Could we capture 1% of the retail market
in Toronto if we open a store there?
Andreas is predictably asking broad questions
while Katie is focusing the analysis on a
specific goal and city.
To answer her question, we’ll need competitor
data in Toronto, our success in comparable
markets, and customer surveys in Toronto asking
about brand awareness.
We have one last question.
Let’s see if Andreas has learned anything
from Katie.
Andreas: Do we have enough employees?
Katie: Given the projects that we have scheduled
for next quarter, do we have enough skilled
personnel to fulfill our commitments?
Clearly Andreas hasn’t quite got the hang
of asking focused data questions.
His question’s still too vague and not actionable
enough for a data analysis.
Katie’s question is well structured so it’s
clear we’ll need to know the size of the
projects, anticipated deadlines, required
skill sets, number of available employees,
and current capacity.
In summary, it might seem like a relatively
obvious point, but don’t underestimate the
importance of framing questions carefully
and thoughtfully before embarking on a data
analysis.
This discipline will help guide your analysis
and ensure you derive meaningful information
from your data.